méfiez vous aider vous l'arsenal de
l'agent secret se perfectionne de jour
en jour à l'appareil photo dissimulé
sous un bouton de manteaux aux postes de
radio récepteur qui tient dans un
poudrier les progrès de l'électronique
miniature réalisée grâce au transistor
est ajouté l'émetteur radio de poche
reliés avec la complicité de la manse
d'un tailleur avec x microphone cet
appareil se place dans un sac comme un
vulgaire paquet de cigarettes et qui
s'il lui même malgré ses réticences joue
un rôle de premier plan puisque c'est ça
laisse qui dissimule l'antenne démission
ce n'est plus qu'un jeu pour être
séduisant agent du contre-espionnage
d'amener son informateur sur un terrain
propice aux confidences
l'infortuné ne se doute pas que la
laisse des titis transmettre fidèlement
ses indiscrétions à une voiture radio
capter et enregistré sur bande
magnétique
elles seront plus tard à témoignages
accablants ce soir qui restera à la
maison car cette fois l'antenne
démission est dissimulée dans la culture
du bas
ce banc qui cette fois retransmettra
monsieur voa prudence verbal méfiez-vous
les progrès de l'électronique ouvre une
carrière qui n'est pas près d'être
encombré mon dieu que les hommes sont
belles